well every time something comes out for
this movie a new quote from a critic
it's always the most insane [ __ ] I'm
hearing guilty don't say you weren't a
v-club just like wow that sounds insane
that feedback hey reject nation how you
doing it's Greg Alba hey it's Kasey you
can follow her on Instagram and Twitter
please do or else you'll never come back
and just we're not real friends we're
Hollywood friends you know networking is
all we're about whoa
Casey that's how she isn't real life
over-reactive hypersensitive hey it's
hereditary transition hereditary trailer
oh good good she didn't even know I was
talking about it said it Charlie
nickname I saw the first trailer before
this it was a gnarly ass trailer dude
okay I'm really gnarly asked trailer
let's see this one let's see it was
anything different you did not see the
first trailer no I don't know what this
is that makes me happy let's watch this
[Music]
my name is Amy my mom died a week ago
she was a very private woman she wasn't
altogether there at the end
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I don't like horror movies
lately top of that was like a day in the
life of you does every morning do that
on purpose
Thanks it's from a reaction indie flick
until everyone like caught on fire I'm
really looking forward to this movie man
because it seems to have one of those
interesting physical allegories of some
type of grief she loses her mom and the
kid loses your grandma and a bunch of
crazy [ __ ] starts happening because of
that and it's called hereditary so it
looks like a lot of the crazy physical
horror stuff is probably just all within
the mind I don't know if it's actually
all really happening I'm sure some of it
really is but that would also make sense
by a lot of things kinda just pop at you
this is good casting the mom I've seen
her in so many Toni Collette yeah yes
she's always very good but I haven't
seen her do like a horror I mean she was
the mom in the sixth sense but she's not
really involved in the scary stuff we go
back and look at the kid
there's just something it's kind of
perfect for this piece well the kid
looks like a normal kid right the kid
looks like a like a regular like a
Hollywood isn't like oh you got a stage
mom behind this camera don't you I don't
know she doesn't have this like cliche
look about her know which I appreciate
everything is orange and blue did you
notice that mm-hmm
did not notice they're not like the
house before you notice production is
I'm pretty well most movie posters are
orange and blue let's see blue and
orange Hey facial eyes you got here
you're smart over here this is my kind
of horror movie because I love a
character based frantic piece I mean
some people might like the the more mood
pieces yeah how do you see the movie
mother I didn't because I was advised
not to okay well my movie gets like
batshit it gets crazy and this feels
like it's gonna have a similar thing
where it just gets progressively more in
same as the film keeps going like the
first trailer was absolutely terrified
this one was pretty scary but it's a lot
shorter his film was gonna have this
effect we're like okay it starts off
like I think I can handle this guy
eerie whatever I always like the head
banging and stuff yeah the things you do
to wake up in the morning be freaking
nervous well hopefully you watch this
movie I don't think so just based on
this alone it looks like a good date
movie oh my god good because I would be
like clutching yeah and he'd be like
flexing would be a good time for you
especially for him alright guys well
that was hereditary you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about get notified
every time our VIP reciate
hey case on Instagram and Twitter
nofollow I think I'm just dehydrated
yeah let's call it a night